>> I could tell you all sorts of things about
Paul, but I'm not going to because I think
his message is just too important to Ident
anymore. So without any further ado, I'd like
to welcome Paul Brest. Thank you.
>> BREST: I wonder whether the talk should
be called, "Philanthropy, with or without
anesthesia," based on that accompanying metaphor.
So, how Harvey is sorry that he couldn't be
here with me, my co-author. But it also will
allow me to kind of say some things that he
might disagree with. I'll talk a little bit--I'm
not going to talk about the book as such except
to tell you that our notion was that this
is the book that would be found in the self-help
section of bookstores. But it would be of
an airplane bookstore, airport bookstores,
but it would be in the executive air terminal.
That hasn't yet been realized. Afterwards,
we can, you know--I'm happy to tell you something
about the process of writing a book--a number
of you--probably many of you have written
a code with other people. And writing a book
with one other person has its own complexities,
not different ones from--when you're sharing
a code. What I want to talk about is not the
book as such, but the only thing I really
know about, which is, is strategic philanthropy,
and that's what the book is about. And strategic
philanthropy is basically about reaching a
goal. And I'm going to use the metaphor of
a destination--probably go further with it
than you think makes any sense. But I want
to begin by saying strategic philanthropy
has nothing to say about what your goal should
be. If you think about traveling, you know,
you might decide you want to go to Africa
to work for the Peace Corps or go to Mount
Everest to climb it or go across town to see
Aunt Sally or go to a bank to rob it. And
that's--those are pre-strategic decisions,
right? It's only after you choose the goal
that you can figure out the best way to go
there. And so too in philanthropy; there are
also its impossible goals. And what strategic
philanthropy doesn't say which goal to choose,
it tells you--it's a framework, really, for
how to get their best. You know, there's this
old saying from the Cunard (ph) lines which
used to have--maybe they still have cruises.
They used to have great trench--oceanic service.
And it was getting there that is half the
fun. Well, what's really important about strategic
philanthropy is getting there. If it's not
fun on the way, then you're probably not going
to continue doing it. But the real objective
is not the fun of the journey, it's getting
there. So I want to talk about what I think
are the basic elements. We already--I'll come
back a little bit, but it's having a clear
goal, having a strategy for achieving the
goal. The strategy needs to be based on a
sound theory of change, which is the sort
of non-profit term for the theory of how the
world works. You need feedback and you need
to talk about risk. So I'm going to begin
by talking about some earlier philanthropists.
Does anybody recognize these guys? Ferdinand
and Isabella, right? Ferdinand and Isabella
are my philanthropists, and their goal was--I
would think you could describe it too. One
of their goals was to have their grant to
get to India, but it was better trade routes
to the Far East. More effective--I should
say, by the way, that--and motives are really
not important in understanding strategic philanthropy.
But it's interesting to think about their
motives. They were--they had some purely unself-interested
motives. They were interested in spreading
Christianity to the world. But they were obviously
interested in their own, in their country's
welfare, which was probably not distinguishable
at that time. So you could think of them as
sort of early mission-related philanthropist
in the same way that Google's philanthropy
is mission-oriented as well; doing good but
also connected with the company's mission.
So people's goals can change over time. Indeed,
the very process of pursuing your goal may
give you some different goals. But at any
given time, you need to know of where you're
going, right? That's sort of a tenant of strategic
philanthropy. It maybe fun to toddle around
in the--I wonder what is blocking the top
of the thing. Well, it doesn't matter, as
long as we can see part of the pictures. You
know, that no one is going to pay it on profit
organizations just to go sailing around the
bay, sailing around the bay just for the fun
of it. You need to have some sort of destination.
Okay. So before, you know, no philanthropy
happens on a blank slate, right? There's always
something that has gone before. And the first
thing to do if you're a philanthropist starting
in an area is learn what the relevant knowledge
is in the field. At this point, Ferdinand
and Isabella looked to the Hogwarts Press'
classic book on, "Navigation In The 15th Century."
And they learned about navigation, whether
ships--whatever they need to learn about.
Well, I'm talking about philanthropy that
is grant-making philanthropy. And if you're
a grant maker, you need to look for a grantee.
So maybe what Ferdinand and Isabella had in
mind was Horatio Nelson, a great--since I'm
playing [indistinct] with history, you know,
a great leader of a great organization, the
British Navy. For better or worse, they ended
up with Columbus as their grantee. So you
have a goal, you have a general approach at
this point. You've done due diligence and
you've found your grantee. And--but you need
to have a strategy for achieving your goal.
And in this case, the strategy was sail west.
Up to this point, trips from Europe to the
Indies had taken Eastern water routes. They
had very often taken parallels overland routes
and here the idea was sail west. A strategy
is only as good as the theory that underlies
it, right? So in this case, the theory which
you're all familiar with is--that the earth
is round. And by the late 15th century, most
educated Europeans thought that the earth
was round. There were some serious mis-estimations
in just how large it was. But without a theory,
as you'll see, I mean, it make sense to engineers
for sure, your strategy is not going to work.
Well, let's--we'll return to Columbus. But
let's talk about philanthropy. So at this--in
some ways, I'm just giving you, you know,
a short list of thousands of possible philanthropic
goals. These are goals that people are actually
pursuing, and so, reducing meth abuse in Montana,
preventing malaria in Africa. I put in the
two sides of say, proposition A, promoting
and opposing gay marriage to emphasize that
point that I've said earlier, which is you
can be strategic in achieving any goals and
you can be strategic in--on opposite sides
of an issue. So there were philanthropies--individual
philanthropies and--at least in some foundations
on both sides of proposition eight. Being
strategic doesn't mean you're on the right
side; it means you're using your resources
as best as possible to achieve your goals
whatever they happen to be. I'm going to use
the last of these examples. Achieving education
for better outcomes for disadvantaged children
in Philadelphia, which is a goal that, you
know, no one would be on the opposite side
even if that is not your passion. And I use
the example for some reasons that I will explain.
So here's a general goal. Once again, you
need to do due diligence. You want to find
a good leader of a good institution and, you
know, then the philanthropist might have looked
for a charter school, organization school.
They might have decided to look for a different
place in Philadelphia. But in this case, look
for, you know, found the school superintendent
of Philadelphia, a good leader of a good school.
I think before--I think I've gotten a little
bit ahead of myself because what I like you
to do is take a minute. And I've given you
a hand-out sheet and, you know, if you have
a pen or pencil and willing to use a low tech
device like that, just jot down; and if you
don't, just keep it in your mind. What is
the goal--whether you have done philanthropy,
you know, from your checkbook or have a donor
advised fund or just do interest in philanthropy,
choose a goal that you're really excited about,
something that motivates you as a goal for
your own philanthropy. Let me take just a
second to let you think about that. All right.
So, I won't to ask you to do the due diligence
part, but we'll come back to some other parts
of the form. So, just as Columbus and his
philanthropist had to learn from the field,
there's a lot of learning--there's a lot of
information out there anyway about what might
improve the outcomes for disadvantaged kids
in Philadelphia. Some places have tried dressing
the kids in school uniforms, Teach for America,
you know, has bright, committed kids from
university starting to teach, KIPP academies
have long school days and long school years,
and so on, and so forth. What's really important
is that you have some reason to believe that
the activity you're engaging--having school
uniforms, whatever it is, leads to better
outcomes. You need to fill in, and this is
sort of a basic tenant of strategic philanthropy
or any sort of strategy. You need to fill
in the blank, and you can't rely on a miracle.
If you haven't filled in the blank between
your activity and the outcome you have, and
sometimes it's the number of steps you need
to fill in, then you expect the miracle to
happen. And, you know, social change is so
hard that the likelihood of a miracle is really,
really small. So take a moment. You set out
a goal, take a moment and jot down for yourself.
I'm not--nobody is going to call on you to
answer this. What is your general strategy
and what is the theory that underlies it?
The equivalent of sale west being the strategy
and the earth is round being the theory. Now,
what's going to get you to your philanthropic
goal? Well--so there was an overall strategy
that Columbus had and Ferdinand and Isabella,
his philanthropists. But an overall strategy
like sail west needs to be implemented, right?
It's pretty vague. So what you need next is
a plan. So--oh, I'm sorry. Once again, I'm
ahead of myself. So the particular strategy
we're going to use in this example, by the
way, is adaptive learning. And let me tell
you what adaptive learning is in the Philadelphia
example and then we'll come back to Columbus.
Adaptive learning is the idea that the teachers
make plans for each student individually.
They see how the student is doing. They give
the student feedback based on how he's doing;
they then change the lesson plan as necessary.
So it's a continuous loop in--and the theory
is that that will lead to better educational
outcomes. And I use it--the reason I like
it because I think it's a metaphor for philanthropy
as you'll see by the time we're done with
this, that philanthropy also is adaptive and
feedback plays a really important rule. All
right. So back to what a plan is, though.
So, it wasn't just enough to say, you know,
like sail west, they need Columbus needed
and a philanthropist needed a business plan,
you know, how they need to buy and provision
the ships and recruit a crew, but then you
also need to chart the course. You need to
chart the course as well. And so, too, you
know, a school example, you know, adaptive
learning is a kind of broad idea. But you
need to implement it. So you need to train
the teachers in assessment, the teachers need
to specify achievement goals for each student,
they need to translate those into assessments
for each student and its sort of a recursive
process which ultimately leads to improved
outcomes. So my question for you is what's
your plan? That would probably take longer
to really specify, but, you know, you had
a general strategy. What do you actually need
to do to make it work? For example, if the
goal--if you're interested in reducing teen
pregnancy, then you probably have a teen pregnancy
clinic and the strategy would be to recruit
the kids you thought you wanted to work with,
to recruit counselors and so on and so forth.
So what would be a strategy for achieving
your goals? Well, I'm not going to call on
anybody to be great during the discussion
if you can allude to some of your own examples.
Okay. Something that's really helpful in philanthropy
is to have targets, right? So the target for
them, Isabella and their grantee, Columbus
was India. In this case, the philanthropist
and the school superintendent have agreed
that in 2008, only 60% of fifth graders were
doing math at grade level and the goal is
by 2012, to have 80%. You might say, "Gosh,
you know, I mean, why not aim for a 100%"
because the target--you've done fundraising
campaign. So the target needs to be ambitious,
but realistic. There's sort of two reasons
to have targets. One is you hold--everybody
knows what they're aiming for, you hold yourselves
accountable to try to achieve it. There's
another reason that's sort of structural.
There's nothing like a target to clarify what
your goal is, right? As between going to the
less improved outcomes for disadvantage kids
and saying, "This is actually what we want
to accomplish." You know, you know if you're
there, you know, you know if you've gotten
to India. So you might jot down the target
for, you know, a--it could be ideally numerical,
but it might be a qualitative target that
you and somebody else could agree--that you
would achieve it or not, how you would know
whether you would actually achieve your goal.
So, I now come to kind of one of the weakest
parts of philanthropy. Surprisingly, we called--though
I think there's work in remedying it, and
that is getting feedback. Oh dear, I don't
think Columbus is--so, that's okay. So what
Columbus had, you know, Columbus basically
relied on a compass and dead reckoning. And
we were talking before about flying. If you
have ever flown a plane or had gone on a boat,
you can start off with a great compass heading.
You can even know what the winds are, but
if you don't have some other form of feedback,
you're going to be off course very soon. After
awhile came the sextants and a--actually,
the result of a great philanthropic contest,
the ships goniometer, which is a way of keeping
track of longitude and latitude. And now,
my guess is that those of you who drive to
work probably have a GPS system in your car.
I mean, feedback is absolutely essential.
Dead reckoning doesn't work with flying and
sailing, and it sure doesn't work in social
change. So how do you track in this Philadelphia
school example whether we're on the course?
Well, we said initially, you know, in order
to make this work; teachers need to be trained
in assessment. Well, you see whether the teacher
show up for training. You may give them little
spot quizzes. They need to specify achievement
for the--targets for the kids. You may rely
on self-reporting. You may kind of randomly
sit in and see how they're doing. But they're
also some ways of assessing whether they're
on course. The issue at this point is not
whether they achieve the ultimate goal, but
are they--are they on course toward achieving
it? And a question for you, not surprisingly,
is how would you track progress for your goal?
Not whether you would have gotten there. Not
whether you had saved whatever part of the
world you're trying to save in your own philanthropy,
but how would you know if you're on the way?
To go back to my example, if it's a teen pregnancy
prevention clinic and part of it is counseling
kids, then if the kids--you need to know whether
the kid show up, whether the counselor show
up and whether there are counseling sessions,
and you might want to know what actually goes
on in the counseling sessions. So, Columbus'
tracking was as good as it could be at that
time. The basic theory of change, the basic
idea that the earth was round was right. But
the map was sort of incomplete as you know.
And Columbus' voyage turns out to be an example
of failed philanthropy, right? The crew may
have been really happy in where they ended
up. But the philanthropists were disappointed
in the result. There's a lot of failed philanthropy.
I mean, a lot of philanthropy is like this
in the sense that it's high risk. The likelihood
of achieving your outcome is not so great.
Of course, unless you're clear about what
your goals are, and that's why targets help,
you don't even know whether you achieve your
outcome as well. So how did our project in
Philadelphia work? Well, then if you look
at a whole lot of different studies not in
any one city, adaptive learning has--can make
a huge boost especially for disadvantaged
kids, seven-tenths of the grade level. Did
it actually work in Philadelphia? You know,
I don't know. For one thing, the reason I
use Philadelphia as an example was, it's the
only place where I could see something that
said Philadelphia, the name of the school
district. I couldn't find the slide that had
other school there. So it's hypothetical.
But there are a lot of reasons that adaptive
learning might work in general and might not
work in a particular case. It might be that
the population is a different one or if it's
just not implemented very well. Why, because
I mean, you know, implementing any social
change strategy and educational strategy,
for example, is difficult. So I mentioned
the failed philanthropy of Ferdinand and Isabella,
and let's talk a little bit about risk in
philanthropy. The risk for Columbus and his
grantee were--all the risk of navigating in,
you know, navigating the ocean in those days.
And the rest of the crew might mutiny because
they ran out of provisions or they were afraid
of falling off the face of the earth. And
the risk of falling off the face of the earth,
that was a possibility. For most philanthropy,
the risk is not endangering life and limb,
although sometimes it is. It's that that you
have put money into something. You put a lot
of money into something and it just doesn't
turn out to work. And you might think for
a moment about what the risks are in your
own plans, where could things go wrong in
a way in your own strategic plan that the
money would turn out to be wasted. Where are
the possibilities for failure the greatest?
How do you know if a risk is worth taking?
Because I'm going to suggest--when I think
about the work of the Hewlett Foundation where
I work, I would say that a huge amount of
the philanthropy we do has a lower than fifty-fifty
chance of succeeding. So how do you think
about risk? Well, some of you are probably
familiar with kind of a simplified version
of expected return. Expected return is the
benefit of everything works out, discounted
by the possibility that it won't work out
over the cost. And what I want to suggest
is this is a healthy way, a good way of thinking
about risk even if you can't quantify. And
I think philanthropy could do a lot more of
work in quantifying, both what the benefit
is and what the probability of achieving the
benefit is than we do for the most part. But
even if--even where you can't quantify, the
first point of it is we think this way in
everyday life, right? We certainly think about
business investments, right? And so, you--I
mean, this is a hard time to talk about what
a safe--what a safe investment for your personal
IRA is. But, you know, you can put it onto
your mattress or put it in a government bond,
and it's very little risk and low return or
you can put them something riskier. We think
about it when we get car insurance, when we
go out of [indistinct] and somebody tries
to sell us an extended warranty for the product.
Probably not a good idea, but--so we think
about it--I think it's a good way to think
about philanthropy for these reasons. First
of all, if you don't recognize the risk, you're
not going to know how to mitigate them. All
right? If you don't know where the dragons
are if you're crossing the ocean, you're not
going to know how to avoid them. And philanthropy
is full of dragons. And it justifies--this
is the expected return approach, it justifies
high risk, high return ventures. The Hewlett
Foundation has made the single largest commitment
in its history, $100 million a year for five
years to support work, to reduce climate change.
In fact, Hal Harvey, my co-author, we spun
off an organization that he's running called
ClimateWorks. The likelihood that all of the
philanthropy together is going to change government
policies that will ultimately change CO2 emissions,
I would put it far less than 50 percent but,
boy, is the impact important if the theory
of change is right. And we have good reason
to think that it is that CO2 emissions do
cause global warming. And global warming is
likely to do damage. If there is--the word
"failure" is a dirty word in the non-profit
sector in general and in philanthropy. And
talking about risks is a way of talking about
failure in a rational way. I mean, there's
no venture capitalist who doesn't expect quite
a few of his or her investments to fail. And
philanthropy is not all that different. And
it can help understand your own risk tolerance
as an individual or foundation. Some people
are willing to take huge risks. Others want
things to be safer. So let me stop there.
Actually, one--I want to show you one last
slide. Then I want to leave time for Q&A.
So I was thinking when I thought that hell
wasn't going to be here, this is the one picture
in the--but we have a few cartoons. In this
one picture that we designed and this is hell's--among
hell's many contributions, but somehow, I
think hell is the proudest stuff in the book.
And it's a way of thinking about your own
philanthropy, which is--imagine a scale--you
can have a more complicated scale but imagine
three vectors. One is the problem that you're
dealing with. You can talk about philanthropy
in terms of opportunities or problems. I think
problem orientation is probably a good way.
Is the problem you're dealing with one that
affects the quality of life or does it affect
life itself? So quality of life, you might
decide, you know, to build a football field
or supports arts organizations in your community.
And the other extreme is the extinction of
life or much of it through nuclear proliferation,
nuclear explosion, climate change, what have
you. That's one axis. Another one is the problem
you're dealing with the danger, reversible
or not. That is the vertical axis. So, you
know, air pollution is actually quite easily
reversal. You stop the pollution one day and
it ends the next. Water pollution is usually
reversible and they take decades to do it.
Loss of bio-diversity is irreversible unless
Google comes up with some great new convention.
And then, what's the scale of it? And scale
can mean lots of different things. Once can
be--is it local and kind of tangible? You
know, the high school football field, it's
local. Or, you know, at the other extreme--you
know, is it--is the scale of one that is distant
and going to affect huge numbers of people
who are anonymous to you. Well, you could
think of this as the small cube, being issues
that are local, reversible quality of life.
And then you can imagine some issues, and
I think climate change, nuclear--the dangers
of nuclear explosion are in and all of the
scales there in the big cube, right? They
threaten life itself. They're distant, anonymous,
and irreversible. It's maybe a way of thinking--and
of course, you don't--you can have mid points
of any of these and you can be at one end
of the spectrum on one of these vectors, and
another, and another. I think a lot of people
at the beginning of their own philanthropy,
tend--I think my own personal philanthropy
is being very much in the small cube, right?
You want things that are local, tangible,
your college, your high school, your town,
your symphony orchestra. And then some people
branch out. How has a very clear normative
view about this? Barely disguised in the book,
which is being out in the outer cube dealing
with the big problems is what should be done.
And I think--I think for established foundations.
That maybe right. But my own view is that
we, you know, that the different people need
to find their different comfort level. You
can deal with the same essential problem on
different levels. So why don't I stop there
and--it says, "The end," that's a good place
to stop. And let's open it up for conversations.
What did I say that you found utterly wrong
or annoying and in need of correction, and
what are your own thoughts on some of these
issues. And if you want to allude to your--you
don't need to, but if you had some thoughts
as you jotted down your own thoughts, your
own philanthropic strategy, that's fine.
>> So, I'm not sure if I can articulate this
point clearly but much of what you said seems
to apply in the context of large foundation
such as the Hewlett Foundation where there's
a large sum of money that needs to be invested
so that you could make significant social
change with this. But for those of us who
have more modest means, shall we say, the
philanthropy we do is unlikely to have a significant
impact like this. And so, in our own giving,
for example, we've often given through intermediaries,
whether they'd be foundations or disaster
relief organizations, or what have you. So
intermediaries that have presumably much more
significant means and you're adding a little
to it. How does this idea of strategic philanthropy
help for individual contributors with modest
means? It's not--as clear to me.
>> BREST: Well, I-I think that's--the book
says--this book is written for anybody who
gives away between $100,000 thousand and $100
million a year. And I think your question
is right. How--you can't do the kind of due
diligence that Ferdinand and Isabella do when
you're giving away the amount of money that
most of us in this room, myself included,
do for our personal account. What aspects
of strategy work? Well, one is being clear
about your goals, you know, for example, you
know, what do you expect before you look for
the organizations, if you're doing disaster
relief or trying to reduce malaria in Africa.
So, what are you trying to accomplish? And
then, even though you can't do deep due diligence
because you don't have time for it? There
are ways of finding out whether the organizations
that you're supporting are achieving those
goals. I think that personal philanthropy
and most of the non-profit sector are stuck
in an unfortunate cycle where the organizations
provide very little information about what
they're actually accomplishing. I mean you
can get glossy brochures and you may get the
same glossy brochure five times a year in
the mail. But does it say, "What are the organization's
goals? What are its strategies for accomplishing
them? And how well is it doing? Is it--are
they on course? Are they achieving some of
their targets?" So the organizations don't
provide that and individual philanthropists,
most of us, don't ask for it. And I wonder
why we don't ask for it. And I think sometimes
we don't ask for it because we think that
it's not available, and of course, they maybe
not be available because we don't ask for
it. I think the key to this, and I think even
right now--my guess is if do you think about
your own philanthropy, all of us in this room,
we could be more demanding of information
for the organizations and then decide. You
know, this organization really looks like
it's doing a good job. At least they have
a theory of change. At least they have a strategy,
whereas some of us don't. I think the key
to this ultimately lies in Web-based devices.
There are few interesting experiments where
organizations. In order--the Greater Kansas
Community Foundation has a Website for all
of its donors. And the organization who wants
to be listed on the Website has to at least
have the elements of what we've talked about.
They have to say, "What their goals are? How
they would know--what their targets are? How
they would know if they were achieving it?
And how did they do last year?" And you only
get listed if you have that. Well, Kansas
City donors are becoming better informed,
and I think more demanding. So what used to
be everybody being stuck, you can think of
as rising possibilities. So I think back for
the individual philanthropist, is what you
can do even without giving away $100,000 a
year.
>> So, in fact, to brainstorm just a bit on
this last point. There are all of these charity
rating organizations. I'm blanking on the
names of all of them. But that basically say
how efficient they are in X, Y, and Z. Would
it be a useful exercise to figure out if you
could convince one of these, or one or more
of these organizations to add additional criteria
so that in order to be--in order to be rated,
you know, you get your four-star rating but
you also have to have your theory of change
listed in one of these organizations. I'm
trying to figure out if there's anything individuals
or an organization could do to prod these
charity rating organizations to do that.
>> BREST: Well, that's something which we--we
actually have a small--as you know, we have
a small program in philanthropy of the foundation.
And this is the probably the central thing
we're working on. There is a rating organization
which, at the moment I think, does more harm
than good called Charity Navigator. And it
just presents the financials, so it--you know,
how much--what are your administrative cost?
What are your fund raising cost and--just
looks so where you can get off the internal
revenue code returned, or the internal revenue
return. Well, looking only in financials should
be looking and only at cost mainly, we'll
be looking at one half of the balance sheet
as a business. In every single, you know,
what are you doing this--make any difference.
You can be in an organization with very low
cost and be doing zero in terms of whatever
your philanthropic outcomes are, or an organization
with fairly high cost and just having a terrific
impact. The new head of Charity Navigator
has said that he wants to move to more outcome-oriented
measures. And I think that's been a bit of
peer pressure, it's been people like me and
others saying that they're harmful. We'll
see where it goes. It's much easier to just
look at the metrics of the IRS return than
it is to look at outcomes. And the non-profit
sector to me, you think its strategy--strategic
philanthropy, you could put strategic anything.
I mean, strategy is strategy whether it's
business, philanthropy, public policy. But
a lot of the sector doesn't think or doesn't
know the concepts--not the vocabulary--and
the basic concepts of goal strategy feedback
in the like. And it's odd, isn't it? Because
the same person who's running a non-profit
organization, who can't tell you what their
goals are and how they're going to achieve
it. If they're doing a home improvement project,
you know, they're building a new sun porch.
It can basically do a strategy in this way.
So it's a matter, I think, of educating the
organizations. And I think that the Web-based
services like this are going to make all the
difference. Yes.
>> Hi. I have a question about risk. If you
are strategizing about how to go about your
project and you discovered that the risk is
extremely high, how do you--how do you work
through that in a sense of being able to solicit
funds or making--or persuading people to come
to your cause if you know specifically that
there is a high risk? And I know you're saying,
"Well, the payoff has to be extremely high."
But how do you advance that argument? What--you
know--what has been your experience on addressing
risk?
>> BREST: All right. So, in some ways, it
could be that the non-profit sector has benefited
from the fact that nobody ever talks explicitly
about what the risk is. And that, you know,
if you put your money into something and the
organization says, "You know, there's only
one-in-a-hundred chance you will succeed.
That may de-motivate people." Let me come
back to that respond. But then talk about
the problem of de-motivation. But if you think
of--if you actually think about the charity
that any of us do. But if you're giving to
a high school football team or to the San
Francisco symphony, which the Hewlett Foundation
does, the latter, not the former, the risks
are very low, right? And, you know, non-profit
arts organizations are in a lot of peril right
now. But the San Francisco Symphony is going
to be here next year and your contribution
to it is going to help. But think about work,
whether it's trying to reduce malaria in Africa
or, you know, improve the environment in some
part of California. We put money into something
which is, it doesn't seem all that risky,
which is improving air quality in the central
valley, Fresno, and other areas where diesel
and other pollutions just makes it--makes
people very sick. The work--because the work
is policy change and any work that involves
policy change is high-risk. There's no assurance
that we're going to succeed or other foundations
working in this are going to succeed. And
you can succeed and then there can be a setback,
right? So that the economic problems of the
valley have resulted in what looked like we're
on a trajectory to success suddenly being
cut because it costs money to reduce diesel
pollution. I guess I think that this is maybe
more optimistic than realistic that if organizations
are really candid about the risk, but also
what the potential returns are, that, that
will create a conversation at a more--at a
higher and more realistic level. You know,
every time somebody puts money into cancer
research or research on any disease, the likelihood
that a particular research team is going to
come up with something is very low. You hope
that enough people will put enough money into
different approaches. I just want to say one
thing about--you know, I teach in my--I continue--I
used to be at Stanford. I continue to teach
one course on judgment and decision making
in a public policy program. And the judgment
decision making literature which as how people
actually--It's not the normative literature
of how--you know, what a good model for decision
making is like and the expected returns, how
do people actually make decisions, has sort
of some depressing thoughts for a strategic
approach to philanthropy, which is when people
start being very cognitive rather than emotional
about philanthropy, they give less. If you
want to--there's a depressing experiment where
if you want people to give for hunger in Africa
and you show them a picture of one starving
child, they'll give this much. If you show
this child and then give statistics about
starving children, they will give less. So
it looks like it may actually involve different
parts of your brain, and when the cognitive
rather than the emotional parts of the brain
light up, you become less philanthropic. I
don't think that's an issue for philanthropy
for foundations, especially where you're giving
away other people's money. But I--it's a little
bit worrisome in terms of asking organizations
to be really articulate about their goals
and their achievements. Go ahead.
>> Hi. Thanks for the talk. It's been very
useful. I have an example--and there are few
examples like this of philanthropic projects
where many of the steps seem to be kind of
not applicable. And so, I'm going to give
the example of proposition eight, right? So
the goal is clear. The strategy is reasonably
clear. There's an organization called "No
One Profit," and you would donate to them
and they had a set of things they were planning
to do. There was actually no way to track
progress. We have no unascertained date whether
you'd succeeded or you'd fail. And the risks
are unknown, right? You don't know what the
chance of success is. How would the Hewlett
Foundation think of a problem like that?
>> BREST: So, policy--a huge amount of the
work we do involves policy change. And I think
you're right that with policy change, whether
it's Prop 8 or Waxman-Markey which, a lot
of our grantees have been working on, you
know, pass the house, the climate cap legislation,
risky in the Senate. Unlike the symphony or
unlike feeding starving children, right? If
you're getting to a food bank, assuming the
place is even halfway while running, you can
find out every additional dollar provides
more food. And it's linear, or more or less
linear. With policy change--and you can think
of prop--know on Prop 8 is being--I mean,
it is, it was attempt to influence policy
not by a legislature but by the whole electorate.
It's not linear. So you can, you know, sometimes
it's all or nothing. And you're going on this
level and you either win or lose. I think
that grantee organizations can be more or
less smart about that. And that, again, this
goes back to the question of how much individual
due diligence you can do. We ended up supporting
the ACOU on this issue. And other foundations
we know supported other organizations based
on their track record. That is how smarter
they are about advocacy. And they just--you
know, so with respect to advocacy, you want
to ask if you have the time, you know, who
are you, you know, what is your strategy,
who are you trying to reach, what voters are
you trying to reach, how are you doing it?
And this year you had an interesting strategy
for trying to get on college campuses, young
voters. And--but I think--let me--so, the
answer is, it's really hard to quantify. And,
you know, Prop 8, sort of whichever side you
were on, you may have thought it was so important
that no matter what the risks are, it was
worth doing it. And in fact, you had enough
public opinion polls to know that the risk
were seem to be roughly 50-50, right, because
I mean the electorate was pretty divided ahead
of time. I mean, I think about the work we
do in climate--we're supporting in climate
change where it has to pass the house. There's
also--I mean the bill has already been watered
down in ways that some environmental advocates
think they'd rather not see it pass. I think
that's wrong. You know, the ex-ante, the probability
of passing the house seemed, you know, lower
than 58 percent. The probably of passing the
Senate seemed--and now seems pretty low. And
of course, for those of you, probably everybody
in this room who knows how to do probabilities,
you have to multiply it, right? So if there's,
you know, a 40 percent chance of passing the
House and a 40 percent chance of passing the
Senate, then the overall chance is pretty
low. So you have to decide it is really important.
But policy change requires a significant appetite
for risk.
>> Okay. I think we're just about out of time
now, so I want us to thank Paul one more time
for coming out and--well, Mr. Brest, thank
you.
>> BREST: Thank you.